>> Greg: YEAH, I MEAN, IT'S
GREAT, BUT WHERE DO YOU PUT THE
$20 BILL?
IT'S FRIDAY!
OR WHAT KAT LIKES TO CALL TGI
WHO THREW UP IN MY CLOSET DAY.
I WONDER IF SHE EVEN REMEMBERS
SINGING TO HER CAT LAST NIGHT?
♪♪
AND I WILL ALWAYS LOVE --
>> ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT, ALL
RIGHT, I'LL STOP.
PLEASE LET GO.
PLEASE.
ALL RIGHT, I'M DONE.
>> Greg: WE UNDERSTAND HOW THAT
CAT FEELS.
BUT MAYBE SHE SHOULD TALK TO
SOMEONE, I SUGGEST HER HUSBAND,
BUT WE STILL CAN'T FIND HIM.
DO YOU RECOGNIZE THIS FACE?
OBVIOUSLY THAT'S A SKETCH.
I THINK WE MIGHT HAVE A PHOTO OF
HIM.
ANYWAY, I'M GLAD JANICE DEAN IS
BACK BUT, YOU KNOW, SHE IS A
RISK TAKER.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: AS THIS VIDEO OF HER
CAN ATTEST.
SHE IS HEALING NICELY.
GOOD NEWS FOR CITIZENS OF
PORTLAND OREGON.
YOU'LL HAVE MORE TIME TO LOOT
BECAUSE THE RIOT SQUAD GAVE
THEMSELF THE BOOTS.
THE GUYS AND GALS ON THE FRONT
LINES OF MAYHEM RESIGNED EN
MASSE AFTER ONE OF THEIR
OFFICERS ALLEGEDLY SMACKED A
RIOTER LAST AUGUST SO ALL 50
QUIT.
CAN'T SAY I BLAME THEM.
THINK ABOUT IT YOU'RE BROUGHT IN
TO STOP A RIOT AND LATELY YOU'RE
BUSIER THAN, CHAOS MAYHEM SMOKE
FIRE, FISTS, THE STENCH OF BODY
ODOR.
LIKE THE REHEARSAL ON THE SET OF
THE VIEW.
AND ALL YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS
CONTROL THINGS AND SAVE LIVES
AND YET YOU GET BUSTED FOR
HITTING SOMEONE AT A RIOT WHO
JUST HAPPENS TO HAVE A CAMERA IN
THE THICK OF IT.
SOMETHING ALEX BALDWIN DOES
EVERY DAY.
YOU SEE HOW IT'S A LOSING
PROPOSITION?
IT'S LIKE APOLOGIZING TO THE
WOKE MOB, YOU'RE DAMNED IF YOU
DO, DAMNED IF YOU DON'T.
OR IF YOU'RE THE REMAINING LAW
ABIDING CITIZENS OF PORTLAND WHO
CAN'T MOVE OUT, YOU'RE DAMNED TO
HELL.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE A MAYOR
THIS PA THEYICALLY WEAK.
>> I'M GOING TO DO THE WORK THAT
I NEED TO DO HERE IN MY LOCAL
COMMUNITY WITH MY LOCAL
OFFICIALS TO TAKE ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR WHAT'S HAPPENING ON OUR
STREET.
AND I'D APPRECIATE THAT EITHER
THE PRESIDENT SUPPORT US OR HE
STAY THE HELL OUT OF THE WAY.
>> I STAND WITH YOU NO MATTER
WHAT.
AND IF THEY WANT THE TEAR GAS
AGAINST YOU, THEY'RE WANTING THE
TEAR GAS AGAINST ME.
>> Greg: HOW ISS THAT APIECEMENT
WORKING OUT?
FACT IS THE DECORATED OFFICER
WAS DOING THE BEST JOB HE COULD
BUT SINCE OUR POLITICIZED
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM HAS NOW
REPLACED AN ACTUAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM, HE'S THE VILLAIN.
HE PAYS, NOT THE CRIMINALS.
JUST THE WAY IT GOES IN A
PROGRESSIVE PARADISE.
LITTLE BACKGROUND ON THAT NIGHT
IN PORTLAND.
ROUGHLY 200 DEMONSTRATORS HAD
APPROACHED THE BUILDING IN
PORTLAND.
THE MEDIA CALLS THEM
DEMONSTRATORS BUT THAT'S LIKE
CALLING ARSONISTS CARLESS
SMOKERS.
THEY CAME WITH TACTICAL HELMETS
ARMED WITH WEAPONRY THEIR
COWARDLY FACES COVERED, EXACTLY
WHAT I WORE IN LARRY KUDLOW'S
HOT TOP.
HE WON'T BE WATCHING THIS, SO...
THEY SAID FIRE THE DUMPSTERS OF
COURSE WHICH RAISES THE E TERM
QUESTION WHY THE HATE AGAINST
DUMPSTERS?
MAYBE IT'S SELF HATRED, CAR
MORTGAGE ATTACKING GARBAGE OR
MAYBE THEY THINK IT WILL STERILE
EYES THE CONTAINER BEFORE THEY
MOVE IN.
THEY DEFACED BUILDINGS, TOSSED
MOLOTOV COCKTAILS SETTING IT ON
FIRE, IN PORTLAND THIS IS KNOWN
AS MAKING S'MORES.
AS IN YOU'RE GOING TO GET S'MORE
RIOTING AFTER YOU DEFUNDED YOUR
POLICE.
SO IMAGINE BEING TASKED WITH
DEALING WITH THESE ANIMALS.
I DON'T EVEN KNOW IF I CAN CALL
THEM ANIMALS, BECAUSE ANIMALS
ARE BETTER CREATURES THAN THESE
BAD LOSERS.
I MEAN HAVE YOU SEEN THE ANTIFA
MUG SHOTS?
BE GLAD THEY'RE NOT SCRATCH AND
SNIFF.
THEY LOOK LIKE THEIR FIGHT FOR
JUSTICE INCLUDES A WAR ON SOAP
AND CLEAR SILL.
THEY COULD BE CAST IN CATS
WITHOUT ANY MAKEUP.
I WONDER HOW CNN PORTRAYS ANTIFA
THESE DAYS.
>> AREN'T THEY JUST KIND OF LIKE
AN IDEA AT THIS POINT OR JUST
PEACEFUL PROTESTERS?
>> YES, A BRILLIANT IDEA.
WE SHOULD HAVE HONORARY DEAGREES
FROM EVERY UNIVERSITY.
OR BETTER YET, A MEDAL OF HONOR,
A NOBEL PEACE PRIZE AND A
STANLEY CUP.
>> SOMETIMES I WISH THEY WERE
CARNIVAL STUFFED ANIMALS THAT I
COULD WIN AND TAKE THEM HOME
WITH ME.
>> I WISH I COULD TAKE THEM HOME
WITH ME SO THEY COULD GET ME
PREGNANT.
>> Greg: I DON'T EVEN THINK
THAT'S AS CRAZY AS CNN NORMALLY.
WHAT IF YOUR JOB WAS TO STOP
THESE VIOLENT CRY TENSE BUT WHEN
YOU DO IT DOESN'T MATTER.
IN OCTOBER LAST YEAR MIKE SUBMIT
GREAT THIRD BASE MAN REJECTED
540 RELATED CASES IN THE
INTEREST OF JUSTICE, CATCH AND
RELEASE.
THESE ARE FELONS NOT FISH.
THAT KIND OF PUNISHMENT WOULDN'T
EVEN MAKE JEFFREY TO BE INPUT
HIS PANTS ON.
THIS IS HAPPENING ALL OVER THUGS
GET ARRESTED FOR CRIMES AND THEN
RELEASED BEFORE THE NEXT PURPOSE
THEY SUCKER PUNCH HITS THE
GROUND.
A RECENT MONSTER WHO SUCKER
PUNCHED AN ELDERLY ASIAN WOMAN
WAS ARRESTED 42 TIMES.
IF ONLY THEY WOULD SEND A SOCIAL
WORKER OR VEGAN CHEF.
YOU WOULD THINK THE JUDGE WOULD
HAVE SEEN THIS COMING WHEN THEY
DID AWAY WITH BAIL.
BUT THEY PROBABLY WENT TO I
HAVEY LEAGUE SCHOOL.
SO WHAT HAPPENS NOW THAN THE
RIOT COPS DON'T SHOW UP FOR THE
WEEKLY RIOT?
THE RIOTORS REJOICE AND THE
REMAINING COPS HAVE NO CLUE WHAT
HAPPENS NEXT, NOT ENOUGH BOOTS
ON THE GROUND, THIS AS MASSIVE
DEMONSTRATIONS ARE PLANNED FOR
THE COMING WEEKEND.
SO THINK ABOUT THE WORLD'S WORST
MAYORS.
YOU HAVE THE HEDGE HOG HOMICIDER
WHO ALLOWED THE GREATEST SAFEST
CITY TO DESCEND INTO MADNESS.
AND THEN TO STEP OVER A DEAD
HEROIN USER.
AND THEN WRITES E-MAIL BILLION
PRIVATE TIME WHILE CHICAGO
CITIZENS DIE.
YOU HAVE THIS SPINALS SACK OF
JELLY THAT DID NOTHING BUT KNEEL
BEFORE THE ARSONIST WHILE THE
CITY OF MINNEAPOLIS BURNED.
AND YOU HAVE THIS PUTZ FROM
PORTLAND.
WOULD YOU WORK FOR CALLING HIM
AN ASS HAT?
CALLING HIS AN ASS HAT INSULTS
ASSES AND HATS.
WHAT DO THESE LEADERS HAVE IN
COMMON OTHER THAN THEY COULDN'T
MANAGE AN ARBIES?
OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE PROGRESSIVE
DEMOCRATS.
WOULDN'T VOTERS LEARN THAT THE
ONLY THING PROGRESSIVES DO IS
MAKE THINGS PROGRESSIVELY WORSE.
>> PERIOD
>> Greg: LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S
GUESTS.
WHEN WEATHER COMES TO NEW YORK
IT HAS TO GO THROUGH HER FIRST,
FOX NEWS SENIOR METEOROLOGIST
JANICE DEAN.
SHE LETS YOU CARRY A GUN IN HER
RESTAURANT SO YOU CAN BET THE
SERVICE IS PROMPT.
COLORADO CONGRESSWOMAN LAUREN
BOEBERT.
HE MADE THE POLICE LOOK SO GOOD,
THEY CANCELLED HIS SHOW.
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK BREAKING
BLUE, SERGEANT SEAN "STICK"
LARKIN.
SHE'S DOWN TO EARTH, ESPECIALLY
WHEN SHE'S PASSED OUT ON THE
STREET, FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT
TIMPF.
>> ALL RIGHT, SEAN, I HAVE TO GO
TO YOU FIRST.
YOU JUST RECENTLY, YOU'RE A
RECENTLY RETIRED POLICE
LIEUTENANT.
THIS IS PART OF A GROWING TREND
THAT'S HAPPENING EVERYWHERE AND
I WOULD SAY THAT THE TREND
ACTUALLY, ACTUALLY, YOU KNOW,
HURT YOUR CAREER.
YOUR SHOW, YOU'VE GOT TO SAY
THIS, ON THE WEEKEND, SO THIS
WAS -- I ENJOYED THE SHOW.
IT WAS BEATING ME IN THE
RATINGS, IN THE DEMO, BUT THEY
CANCELLED YOU BECAUSE YOU WERE
DOING TOO GOOD OF A JOB MAKING
THE POLICE LOOK GOOD, THEY
CANCELLED YOU MAKING MY SHOW
NUMBER ONE IN THE DEMO.
>> FULL CIRCLE
>> Greg: FULL CIRCLE.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: THAT HAD TO HAVE PISSED
YOU OFF.
>> DRAMATICALLY.
AND WE WERE BEATING EVERYBODY.
IT WAS THE NUMBER ONE SHOW ON
FRIDAY AND SATURDAY NIGHTS
TYPICALLY ON CABLE TV.
>> I WAS WATCHING IT.
>> SHE WASN'T EVEN WATCHING OUR
SHOW.
>> I WAS ON THE OTHER ONE.
>> BUT, NO, IT DID.
AND ALL THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
POLICING IN AMERICA, TO ME LIVE
PD, WHAT IT SHOWED WAS, HEY,
THIS IS REALLY WHAT'S GOING ON
OUT HERE.
THERE WAS NOTHING DRAMAITIZED,
THE SHOW, THE PRODUCERS, NOBODY
PICKED WHAT THE OFFICERS DID
EACH NIGHT.
THEY WERE JUST IN THE CARS
DOCUMENTING, HEY, THIS IS LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN THE COUNTRY
>> Greg: RIGHT.
>> AND WE SHOWED TONIGHT THE
URBAN AREAS.
WE SHOWED IT IN RURAL AREAS.
YOU NAME IT, YOU SAW IT.
AND IT'S KIND OF FUNNY BEING OUT
ON THE STREET AS A POLICE
OFFICER WHEN THE SHOW WAS
CANCELLED, EVEN ALL THE BAD GUYS
I SPOKE WITH WERE LIKE WHERE'S
THE SHOW, WE MISS THE SHOW
>> Greg: THAT'S WHERE THEY GET
THEIR BIG BREAK.
>> YEAH
>> Greg: WE HAD A DRINKING GAME
WHEN WE WATCHED LIVE PD.
WE HAD TO DRINK EVERY TIME A
SUSPECT WAS MISSING A SHIRT.
>> THERE WAS LIVE PD BINGO THAT
YOU COULD PRINT CARDS AND PLAY
AT HOME.
SOCIAL MEDIA WAS A WITH BIG PART
OF TWITTER, LIVE TWEETS.
SO YOU GOT TO SEE THIS ALL NIGHT
LONG THE WAY THE VIEWERS
INTERACTED WITH EACH OTHER OR
EVEN US IN STUDIO.
SO A LOT OF PEOPLE MISSED IT AND
FINGERS CROSSED THEY WILL BE
BACK
>> Greg: YOU NEED REUNION SHOWS
WHERE YOU GET THE COPS AND THE
SUSPECTS BACK TOGETHER.
JUST LIKE REAL HOUSE WIVES WHICH
ARE BASICALLY CRIMINALS.
AREN'T THEY CRIMINALS JANICE?
>> YEAH
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF
THIS.
THE WHOLE RIOT TEAM LEAVES.
CAN YOU BLAME THEM?
>> I DON'T.
I'M A FAMILY OF FIRST
RESPONDERS, MY HUB IS A FIRE
FIGHTER AND HIS BROTHER IS A
POLICE DETECTIVE SO I'M IN A
FAMILY WHERE PEOPLE RISK THEIR
LIVES TO HELP OTHERS.
SO TO SEE THIS HAPPENING -- AND
THE FIRE DEPARTMENT AND POLICE
DEPARTMENT ARE KIND OF THE SAME
IN THAT, IF THEY FEEL LIKE ONE
OF THEIR PEOPLE, THEIR BRETHREN
IS AFFECTED, THEY'RE GOING TO
BAN TOGETHER AND DO SOMETHING
LIKE THIS
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> SO I APPLAUD THIS.
I FEEL BAD FOR PORTLAND.
I DON'T KNOW HOW SAFE IT'S GOING
TO BE THERE NOW.
>> Greg: WELL, YEAH.
>> BUT, I MEAN, GOING BACK TO
WHAT WAS GOING ON THERE, THIS
WAS NOT LIKE STOPPING CARS FOR
SPEEDING, THIS IS LIKE VIOLENCE
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> SO WHAT ARE THEY SUPPOSED TO
DO?
JUST STAND THERE AND TAKE IT?
>> Greg: THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO.
BY THE WAY, WHAT DOES YOUR
HUSBAND HAVE AGAINST FIRE?
I MEAN, MAYBE HE SHOULD LOOK IN
THE MIRROR.
WHAT IS FIRE BUT REALLY JUST A
CHEMICAL REACTION LOOKING FOR
LOVE?
>> WOULD YOU LIKE TO CALL HIM
>> Greg: I WOULD.
AND I'M SURE AS A FIRE FIGHTER
HE WEARS A RED HAT, RIGHT?
RACIST.
>> VERY OFFENSIVE
>> Greg: EXACTLY CONGRESSWOMAN.
LET'S SAY YOU WERE A
CONGRESSWOMAN NOT IN COLORADO
BUT IN PORTLAND.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO.
>> I THINK THE PORTLAND CONGRESS
MEN THEY JUST LET INSURRECTIONS
HAPPEN, RIGHT?
IN SEATTLE WE ALLOW CHAZ.
IT'S A PEACEFUL PROTEST BECAUSE
THERE IT'S OKAY.
BUT ACTUALLY IN COLORADO WE'VE
TAKEN AWAY QUALIFIED IMMUNITY
FROM OUR POLICE OFFICERS AND
IT'S DEVASTATING AND NOW THEY
WANT TO DO IT ON A NATIONAL
LEVEL IN CONGRESS, THE HOUSE
PASSED IT AND, YOU KNOW, NOW THE
FEW REPUBLICANS WHO STOOD UP TO
SAY WE'RE NOT GOING TO PASS
THIS, THIS LEGISLATION FOR THE
GOLD MEDAL FOR THE CAPITOL HILL
POLICE BECAUSE THEY WANT TO USE
THEM FOR THEIR POLITICAL GAMES
AND WE'VE ALREADY PASSED IT
ONCE, THEY COME BY, THEY REWRITE
IT, ADD ANOTHER OFFICER IN HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH JANUARY 6TH.
AND THEN WE HAVE OFFICERS GOING
TO MEMBERS OFFICES,
CONGRESSIONAL OFFICES SAYING WHY
DID YOU VOTE NO ON THE GOED
MEDAL BILL.
I HOPE THOSE SAME OFFICERS ARE
GOING TO ALL THE DEMOCRATS THAT
REPRESENT PORTLAND AND SEATTLE
AND ALL THESE OTHER CRAZY CITIES
AND SAY WHY DID YOU VOTE TO
DEFUND US?
WHY DID YOU VOTE TO TAKE AWAY
OUR QUALIFIED IMMUNITY AND MAKE
US PERSONALLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
OUR JOBS?
THESE GUYS LOVE THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND I'M PROUD OF THE
STAND THEY TOOK THERE IN
PORTLAND BECAUSE ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH.
AND I THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE
THIS HAPPENING A WHOLE LOT MORE.
>> Greg: YEAH, KAT, WHEN YOU
LOOK AT PORTLAND, DO YOU THINK
IT'S A LOST CAUSE?
I DON'T FIGURE OUT HOW YOU GO
BACK.
LIKE IF YOU EQUATE ANY KIND OF
LAW AND ORDER OR DISCIPLINARY
ACTION AS AGGRESSION OR AN
AFFRONT, THERE IS NO ANSWER AT
THAT POINT, OTHER THAN THE QUICK
ROLL TO JUST CHAOS.
>> RIGHT
>> Greg: MUCH LIKE YOUR HAIR
TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU.
>> HEY I WOULD TAKE SOME FOX
NEWS HAIR.
>> THANK YOU.
IF YOU WANT SOME I CAN UNCAN
CLIP A PIECE AND SEND IT OVER.
>> AND I'VE BEEN THERE WHEN
SHE'S TAKEN PIECES OUT.
>> I WILL DO IT IN PUBLIC, I
HAVE NO SHAME.
BUT I DON'T DO ARSON
>> Greg: NO, YOU DON'T.
>> OKAY?
AND THE REASON WHY ARSON IS
DEFINITELY NOT AN EFFECTIVE
STRATEGY IS BECAUSE IT'S NOT
ALLOWED.
SO IF YOU DO THE ARSON, THERE
ARE PEOPLE THAT STOP THE ARSON
AND YOU GET IN TROUBLE.
BUT IF YOU ARE ALLOWED TO DO
ARSON, IT'S INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE
>> Greg: THAT'S TRUE.
>> IT'S INCREDIBLY EFFECTIVE
BECAUSE NOW ALL THESE QUIT WHO
IS WHAT THEY WANT.
I'M SOMEBODY WHO WANTS POLICE
REFORM.
I DISAGREE I THINK WE SHOULD
HAVE QUALIFIED IMMUNITY HOWEVER
I STILL THINK THEY SHOULDN'T
HAVE NO POLICE WHICH IS WHAT
THESE PEOPLE WANT.
THEY WANT NO POLICE AND NO
PRISON AND BECAUSE THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO DO UNBRIDLED ARSON
PEOPLE ARE QUITTING A